The next question is hyperthermia unit ideal for some cutaneous lesions that are out of the skin.
So my definition of some cutaneous lesion is still under the skin.
So I'm not sure if I answered this question correctly.
But maybe it's
So bottom line is what is the hyperthermia unit good for?
So the hyperthermia unit will raise the temperature of the tissue down maybe in your soul.
So if your cancer is deeper than that, it may not do anything.
So let's say if you have prostate cancer, should I get a hyperthermia unit?
No, probably not.
If I breast cancer, should I get a hyperthermia unit?
Yeah, maybe. Yeah, that might be perfect for that liver cancer.
I don't know. No, we've had patients with hey, creative cancer that have had have seen phenomenal symptomatic changes in hyperthermia.
The gal who is the researcher from Japan, who I get the hyperthermia that's front is
I hope to be about a month ago about person that she had to do it.
It's just chronic pain issues. I can't remember what it was from.
I think some horrible on a real, but on a real accident that it helped with that person.
So if you have a lesion that is a skin lesion like a skin cancer, hey, hyperthermia might be great for if you have a lesion that's within an inch of the surface of the skin, it might be great for it.
The only thing you have to be concerned with with hyperthermia is if you have an open wound.
And because hyperthermia is killing the cancer by increasing the temperature, but it can also increase circulation.
So you don't want to be just going to watch for bleeding.
But hyperthermia, we.
Clearly impressed with the results that people are having with a spend beneficial.